the Joe Rogan experience glad you
brought up hot baths cuz that's
something that I wanted to cover before
we got off track when we're talking
about sauna when people that don't have
access to a sauna how much benefit can
they get out of a hot bath oh I'm glad
you brought that up because there was a
you know so a couple of things one there
was a study that showed hot baths can
have an antidepressant effect and these
people were put in 104 degrees
Fahrenheit baths where they were up to
their shoulders for like 20 to 30
minutes and the Sham control was like a
green light like so people thought they
were getting a treatment they're getting
some kind of green light therapy or
whatever you know so it was a placebo
control because placebo is definitely
real particularly with depression and it
it had a pretty powerful antidepressant
effect very similar to Charles Rosen
study with the the hyperthermic chamber
thing when you say antidepressant
there's no real way to measure that they
have this whole yeah I mean so there are
some cares potential biomarkers being
identified c-reactive protein being one
inflammation inflammation plays a
there's like a huge link now between the
immune system and chronic inflammation
and depression brain function in general
bringing aging but inflammation so I
mean that's the there's there's a push
for looking but not all depressed
patients have it it's like there's a
subset absolutely active protein but
yeah depressions measured it's a very
much like a you know have someone so a
subjective measurement would be an a
clinical person like measuring a whole
battery of things they do I forgot the
name of the test but yeah that's that's
the test so it's like basically a
battery of feeling things so it's not
like a hardcore quantitative biomarker
which is so badly is needed but um the
hot baths have also been shown so heat
shock proteins which do you like amazing
there's so many amazing things that heat
shock proteins do they've been shown to
prevent muscle atrophy and that's you
know in the brain they're so important
like preventing proteins from
aggregating in the brain that's how I
first got in like one of my first
biological experiments ever because I
was a chemistry major in college
all chemistry stuff organic chemistry
and like chemistry but after I graduated
I went to work at the Salk Institute for
Biological Sciences in Hawaii I was
working in an aging lab and one of the
first experiments I had that I was doing
like one of my first projects was we
were taking the human amyloid beta gene
and and injecting him in these worms
these nematode worms that only live like
14 or 15 days and we were making them
form amyloid plaques in their muscle so
like basically you you look at these
little worms under microscopes is only
like half a mil a half a millimeter you
know they move around and I was like
they get older and they're aging they
don't move as quickly you know they're
kind of slower a little more decrepit
but anyways you give them this amyloid
beta and after like a couple of days
they become paralyzed or they're like
laying and their little petri dish plate
on the e.coli food you're giving them
and they kind of just move around just
to feed like their nose just moving
around and so when we would give them
tons of heat shock proteins in addition
to the amyloid totally reversed it like
completely mmm like they would move
around and be young so anyways heat
shock proteins play a role in like
neurodegenerative disease also some
links to like improving depression in
animal studies but can you measure
heating the bath versus yeah so that's
been done so the sauna I know of one
study where people that sat in a hundred
and sixty-three degree Fahrenheit sauna
for 30 minutes had heat shock proteins
their levels were 50% higher over
baseline and which is great and that
usually like animal studies showed that
that can they can stay elevated for like
48 hours after that there's a hot bath
study where they also elevated it wasn't
quite as high but it was like you know
40 or so percent higher than baseline
levels and it was a hundred and four
degrees but this study instead of doing
it from the shoulders down where I told
you about the depression it was like
only 20 to 30 minutes it was like from
the waist down so they had to stay in
there for an hour it's like a jacuzzi
you know what you're sitting there from
the waist down and like that's hot like
saying 104 that's that's pretty hot but
heat shock proteins did increase so I
think you know for for people that don't
have access to a sauna that hot baths
absolutely are a good modality for heat
stress
and I used it for a long time like I
said I just got us on like I've I've
been I've made a career about taki fed
saunas you know and I just got one like
last month so like like I understand
what it's like to not have a sauna I
have to use hot baths but I was also
using the gym saunas but right now it's
like there's no gyms that are open and
so yeah it is hot baths are like the
only the only really choice if you don't
have a hot sauna no home sauna what
about cold shock proteins and the I mean
how much difference is it between taking
a really cold shower ice bath versus
something like cryo cryotherapy like the
place that I took you to yeah so I mean
there's there's differences in in I mean
so it depends on how long you're staying
in a cold you know water like cold
shower like actually being submerged
like from like if you're like in the
ocean or something or a lake and you're
like from your shoulders down like
that's probably much more powerful than
just having the shower on but by the way
the shower like some days I'm like what
does matter this this is not cold at all
you know it's just so variable where you
like Southern Southern California you
live on the right the border of Mexican
yesterday so so ever so most of time now
I shower right after someone that's like
my shower time now
and so like it's I do about six minutes
and it's so easy for me I totally have
adapted and I'm not sure if I've just
totally adapted or if it's just like my
faucets doesn't get it like just doesn't
get cold that cold like it really
doesn't today I took a cold shower from
home and my son is not there and I did
it just because I wanted to have the
mood affects the north and Efrain that's
been shown to be increased and it was
much colder but then again it was a
different shower hmm I'm not sure if
it's because I didn't have the hot
before you know beforehand like the hot
being hot I'm like getting in the cold
shower like it just feels really good
nice shock but the cold shock you asked
me cold track proteins the that that
hasn't really been measured in humans
what is measured most the time with cold
truck is norepinephrine release and
norepinephrine and plasma and there has
been studies correlating norepinephrine
in plasma upon cold exposure
norepinephrine release in plasma to in
the brain where it's involved with like
mood and focus and attention so there's
been studies we're like you could do a
two minute
cryo whatever the average temperature
it's really cold - 240 something like
that yeah
and then that could be compared to like
you know a longer a longer duration in
50 degree you know I think a 50 degree
fahrenheit water or something like that
I don't remember the exact time but but
it is comparable but you have to stay in
a longer duration so some people prefer
ice baths some athletes prefer the ice
baths versus cryotherapy even though
it's it's probably more painful because
it lasts a lot longer have you done no
no I've done it I've only done the cryo
so I've have you ever done like cold
shower after your sauna yes do you like
it I like it a lot I like it
particularly after hot yoga after hot
yoga after hot yoga spray especially in
the winter when it's actually cold the
water is cold that's when I love it
there's something mood enhancing I mean
these things also affect the immune
system by the way which is also very
relevant both cold and burn and hot they
both have been shown to increase
lymphocyte numbers and also like other
myeloid cells and stuff I mean people
but but like there's something like I've
done the sauna and then gone into an ice
bath and then you know it's just really
it's hard it's cold I mean you feel good
but man you know I think just like got
the guy's house I was doing and I was
trying to impress them so you know I'm
hardcore but it was it was pretty
intense I do I do eventually want to get
some kind of like they have those like
like ice baths that you can like
regulate you like regulate the water
temperature
you know ones that you plug in yeah
they're not ice baths and exactly it's
cool this is too much work like
[Applause]